[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis my friends this
is grunge in here welcome to my 17th
episode of dirty chest tricks against
Sicilian in this episode I'm going to
show you a wonderful attacking line
against classical Sicilian Scheveningen
and some variation of e 6 na Slav
the opening arises after the following
model Evo c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4 C
captures d4 Knight captures before
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now black
can respond in a 3 different manner
Knight to c6 leads to the classical
Sicilian a6 leads to the 7 in gun and a6
still keep in the north of territory
well it doesn't matter to us as after
any moves let's say in this game
black continued with classical Sicilian
setup Knight to c6 against each of this
move our apply is very consistent we are
going to play Bishop to c4 known as
sozin variation and by far all the
theory suggests that as soon as the
bishop appears on the c-4 square black
should neutralize with the MU Isaac's ok
since the white Bishop has been blocked
up we can now easily play the move
Bishop to b3 and again black can deviate
with different kind of moves as I have
highlighted over here but it doesn't
matter to us as our model is very
consistent so for example let's say
after the move Bishop to e7 here comes
the starting point of valley middle weak
attack and this is what I like about
this opening not only it has a fixed
structure so you can easily remember but
not many black players are familiar with
this territory and you can quickly get
an attacking position now before we move
on I like to quickly show you where the
pieces belong so for example here white
will continue with Quint v2 clearing a
path for the queenside castle and
remember guys whenever black played the
moon a six we will always respond with
Bishop to b3 so that black cannot gain a
temple with the move be fine okay
so after Bishop to b3 our next stages we
want to castle quickly on the Queen side
and after that
remember this superb attacking plan G
fall and then G Phi which gives void a
very fun and aggressive position at the
opening stage so this is pretty much of
a plan and once you go through it you
will find out that it is very easy to
remember
now in order to understand this attack I
have picked two games for you one where
black did castle on the Kings side and
the second one where black do not castle
and still find himself on a trouble line
in the first game
black continued with the moon asics and
here a white castle on the Queen side
but personally I think Bishop to b3
is more accurate response anyways Castle
and Quinn to c7 typical classical
Sicilian satyr
and now white place the move Bishop to
b3
so here instead of Castle black choose
the move Knight to e5 attacking the
bishop immediately but you can easily
guess White's next move
yup have a trademark attacking scheme on
the Kings side starting with g4 and
funny enough black can't stop it with
that six as after the match fall GFR is
definitely on the card okay
black continue with defy so he gains
space on the Queen side but I think
black is too slow and white pick up the
pace immediately with GFI black throws
this in between check with Knight
captures b3 and after a captures b3 now
he removed the night with night 27 so
you can see that we have a double edge
position and h4 + f4 can be a good move
in this position but now you're going to
see something very special as we are
going to witness one of the most
devastating bellum Arabic sacrifice and
this is what I like about it boom hahaha
what a move
and you will be surprised that even
black castle we can play this move and
get a hell lot of attacking position
first thing first
Whitey's attacking the bishop and if
black allows white will definitely take
it also white is hitting the g7 so in
the case of Bishop to a fade Bishop to
d4 is a very strong reply so all in all
if black doesn't capture this piece then
he is in a huge trouble so let's check
out what is happening after he captures
f5 which looks obvious response at this
position and here comes the second
important memory marker guys do not
capture fi immediately but throw this in
between move Knight to d5 again hitting
two spots sue black responses force
black has to play Queen to d8 and after
that now we are going to take on fi and
you can see by yourself even though
black is a piece off his legs will be
literally shaking
the first important point you should
note here that black cannot castle at
this point and the reason is very simple
yup Epic's trapping down that black
bishop
you might says hang on but I can take on
f6 right well yes you can but it just
opened up the G file and it doesn't
matter how we were black recaptures
let's say Knight captures f6 we can
throw this deadly check and after this
game is almost over King to H it is a
pretty bad move due to the simple Bishop
to d4 so the best response goes as
follow Knight to g4 blocking the file
but that doesn't stop us as we are going
to go with all of the super sacrifice
Hyup you guessed it rook captures g4
Bishop captures g4 Queen captures g4
check and after King to ratchet and the
move rook to g1 what is simply
threatening a checkmate and believe it
or not it is not easy to defend this
after the only move rook to g8 White has
the winning were in this position push
up to d4 King is completely trapped and
only move AB six fails due to the simple
technique are you ready
Knight captures AB six sacrificing your
queen simply black can take it s at the
end of the sequence Knight captures g4
check King to g8 night to at six double
discover check and after King to f8 and
the move rook to g8 it's a cute
checkmate time
so obviously black can't take of a queen
at this point and the other move Bishop
captures f6 completely fails due to the
simple technique which forces black hand
to capture with the Queen which allows
us to win the piece in a broad daylight
you
so it is pretty clear that here black
has to stop the moon absence and
accordingly in this game where black is
nearly 2200 rated opponent find the
danger and continue with Hep 6 by
himself okay white simply capture on f6
and obviously black cannot capture with
the bishop as after Bishop to b6
discover check black will lose the Queen
so he recaptured with the night
now the third important memory marker
you have to remember in this opening is
whenever the night on d7 moves to the f6
we have the square reckoned for our
Bishop
so our Bishop will literally leap in
which create more conjunction in the
black camp well Black has the only move
Queen to d7 and white can't give a check
and take a look in the corner but I
really like the white approach which he
continued in the game he first take on
AB six so black responses force Black
has to take with the Jeep on and after
that white find this forcing sequence
Queen to h5 check King to f8 and now
very nice retrieving move Bishop to e3
threatening a checkmate sequence black
is obliged to stop this with at six but
to his horror what he found his white
deliver the second dazzling sacrifice
wait
push up to that six back again black
hand is forced he has to capture this
Bishop and after Queen takes King to
here black is trying to run away but
white is not a fool so he first stopped
King to go on the Queen side with Queen
to etch a check and after Bishop to
afaid the simplest continuation in the
world rook check King to d8 Queen check
King to c7 and the easiest move rook to
e7 and black simply resigned the game
so now let's check out what happens when
black castles and we are following a
game where a 2600 literally crushed a
2300 in just a mere 23 moves here black
castle on the Kings side and no prize
for guessing White's next move
yup indeed g4 was on the board
well black immediately get the night off
with Knight to d7 but unfortunately it
didn't stop the typical Bellamy robic
knight sacrifice yup
Knight to a5 so it's amazing that even
black castles what can do such a
sacrifice and again the threats are very
simple so black has to take it and this
time around after Knight to d5 and the
move Queen to d8 we are going to take
with the Jeep on and you can see the
idea is very simple finish the guy on
the G file
black can't play Knight to f6 due to the
simple Bishop to b6 idea which we have
seen in earlier game so in this game
black continue with Bishop to AB 6
and after the obvious move rook to
Jeevan he Park his king in the corner
with King to a jade
okay white says no problem I am going to
come now on the edge file with Queen to
h5 and from here onwards every single
move is purely concentrated on the King
side attack black continue it night to
see if I attacking the weak pawn on e4
but that does help I build up his attack
wait
Bishop captures e5 pawn captures e5 and
now very nice
Luke lift rook to d3 so suddenly from 18
moves black is filling the huge as rook
swinger is coming off with mating attack
so black thought okay no worries I will
play at six first and when white played
the move rook to h3 which has very nasty
threat of Queen captures at six followed
by checkmate black calmly defend
everything with Kingdom at 7:00 so at
first sight this looks like you have
sacrificed the piece and black has
defend everything so now what but can
you believe just one move and black
resigned the game yes you heard it right
kindly pause the video and find out that
super mu white played
you
are you ready I hope you find this
deciding blow boom
well the threat is very simple white
wants to capture on at 6:00 for her bad
rook captures at 6:00 which leads to the
made and if black captured this rook
then we have this forcing checkmate
starting with Queen captures g6 Jack
King to g8 now comes Knight captures f6
double discover Jack and after King to H
it and the move Queen to at seven we
have a picture of checkmate on the board
which black certainly want to avoid so
after 20 root 2 G 6 black resigned the
game
you
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this very aggressive
vulovic attack which involves this nasty
night sacrifice on f5 and it doesn't
matter whether black castles or not the
attacking stuff white GERD is more than
enough to create havoc in the black camp
and win a lot of games thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I will meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care